foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
aren't you glad to live in the Free
State of Florida
[Applause]
we are going to carry this torch of
Freedom onward because our mission is
very simple we are keeping the State of
Florida free thank you all God bless you
all right people we are live on Rumble
YouTube and Blaze TV and yeah a little
heavy-handed I'm pulling the
heartstrings on this Friday before these
midterm elections in three days on
Tuesday when uh yeah it does look like
this red wave is gonna happen but you
never know so please people get out
there and vote I will actually be voting
in person on Tuesday maybe we'll live
stream they don't let you get right up
you can't do it from the booth but maybe
a little bit outside we'll see some
Freedom lovers in Florida and uh and we
will vote and then we will live happily
ever after it is Friday so we got
another round table Extravaganza for you
and joining me today is the host of the
you're welcome podcast Michael malis a
lawyer at the Dillon Law Group Ron
Coleman and host of Viva barneslaw on
locals.com Viva Fray gentlemen welcome
to the show
thank you David TGIF
professional people with me today
finally uh all right guys the theme
today is obviously we're going to have
to talk about the election but really
the thing that's kind of uh coming with
this Red Wave is that the the censorship
situation related to Big Tech does seem
to be crumbling at least a little bit
although I have no doubt that Facebook
and Google and everybody else have more
tricks up their sleeves but Elon did buy
Twitter and now all hell seems to be
breaking loose around that and then
we're going to get into some of the
numbers leading into the midterms uh
before we get to it real quick uh
because the election is just days away
uh and the stakes have never been higher
I think it's time to get this Blaze
midterm little pimp Pam pamphlet that
they've got for you several races across
the country have gotten very interesting
over the past couple of weeks will
Republicans be able to win a senate seat
in Washington state of all places is
Kathy hochel really in trouble in New
York yeah I think so will voters punish
Gretchen Whit for her covid lockdown
insanity and finally give her the boot
there's a ton to cover this election
cycle and the blaze has you covered go
over to theblaze.com election guide and
receive a free copy of Blaze media's
Ultimate Guide to the midterms delivered
right to your inbox that's theblaze.com
election guide and they'll send you
everything you need to know to be ready
for big election night and now back to
me okay so let's do the the tech portion
of this first uh big thing of course in
the last week is that Elon Musk is now
the CEO of Twitter he felt that going to
Mars wasn't enough and he walked in to
Twitter offices with the sink
foreign
let that sink in people you get it uh
Benny Johnson on Twitter friend of the
show uh he was one of the first people
to break that Elon Musk had fired Vijaya
got a the head of legal policy trust and
safety who made the decision to
permanently suspend Donald Trump and you
guys remember her she of course was the
one who went on Joe Rogan's podcast with
Tim Poole and pretty much dropped the
ball we should have seen all of this
coming so let's start with that Viva I
uh take it well first off you're a new
Floridian everyone knows that you fled
Canada you're here in free Florida uh
but you pay attention to a lot of the
tech stuff I mean this this Elon thing
this is all good for people that like
free speech and freedom right well okay
it's it's a risk first of all that the
joke let that sink in makes no sense if
you don't understand he's bringing a
sink in I thought it was a computer and
it took me forever to get the joke it's
an actual sink
it looks good he's certainly been
walking the walk to some extent I still
have my own concerns because Elon is
involved in businesses that rely on
government authorization government
approvals to some extent he's not
corruption free he's not blackmail free
it's conceivable he might succumb to the
pressure of don't do certain things
um on Twitter or we might frustrate some
of your other businesses which are
heavily reliant on government
authorization but so far so good and
anything that makes AOC unhappy might be
a good thing to a great many people all
right perfect segue so let's get to the
AOC stuff and then malice I want you to
comment on that so AOC she's not happy
that a billionaire is going to own
Twitter she seems to have no problem
with the billionaire who owns the
Washington Post but that's a separate
aside here's a tweet from AOC LMAO at a
billionaire earnestly trying to sell
people on the idea that free speech is
actually an eight-month subscription
plan to which Elon Musk replied your
feedback is appreciated now pay eight
dollars and then in perfect troll form
he posted this from aoc's website yeah
she sells a sweatshirt on her website
for uh 58 just on the factual side of
this thing Elon is not going to charge
everyone eight dollars he is potentially
going to charge people eight dollars to
be verified so that you would know that
you're talking to the real person uh
malice you must love the troll portion
of this right that Elon is not just that
he bought the thing and that maybe Free
Speech will be defended a bit more uh
but the troll part is kind of this is
malice territory can we put her
sweatshirt up again did you guys notice
she's got those upside down exclamation
points around Ocasio
because you know if you're writing in
Spanish you're going to have an upside
down exclamation point in the middle of
someone's name that's just logic um I
absolutely love it and I absolutely love
that uh not only is Elon taking the
fight to these horrible people another
good example Dave was earlier in the
week when Stephen King America's
favorite aging lesbian uh was stamping
her feet about how I'm not gonna pay
twenty dollars a month to be verified
the guy's worth nine figures and Elon
Musk is like hey how about eight dollars
and he had no reply because for years
Twitter has been a safe space for
members of the enemy class they can spew
their nonsense and know that they would
have no repercussions the best example
of this of course was in covid uh when
they can spread complete lies such as
the fact that we need social distancing
such as the fact that if you have the
vaccine you're not going to spread it to
other people and no if anyone who
challenged them on this lost their
entire accounts let alone the ability to
just tweet one or two things about it so
I I don't like the term Free Speech
because it gives the impression that
everyone has something to say which I
don't believe in but I do like the idea
that people who have for literally over
a century have been in a position to
monologue or have all the flow of
information go in One Direction are now
in a space where they're going to have
to respond to people and I've been
ratioing them left to right left and
right keep in mind like when you had the
powers that be being on their side they
were taking L after L after L on Twitter
now it's going to be complete Carnage
and I for one could not be happier and
for the portion of my audience that is
not on Twitter and I often say God bless
you and don't get on there I mean the
the change in Twitter just in these few
days while clearly they haven't fixed
all of it yet I mean I'm gaining
followers again I was purging thousands
sometimes a day before that for the last
couple of months and the engagements
Rising again I mean obviously they have
to go through and find all the Gremlins
in the system and all that stuff but I
know we can say a ton of great things
about Elon so I want to actually focus
on part of what Viva said there for a
second uh Ron what do you think about
just the fact that he has all the these
other business concerns and now he's
getting involved in this thing it's like
I know it's hard to run one company now
the guy's trying to go to Mars and build
underground tunnels in Los Angeles and
run Twitter and starlink and a whole
bunch more it's a lot right oh it's a
lot but
you know uh Elon Musk is a
it's quite a lot of man uh you know and
you know when we talk about running
things it's like when people talk about
running the country president doesn't
run the country the president doesn't
even run the government in fact under
Trump the president didn't even run the
White House
he's not gonna he's gonna do what he
wants to do right now his his attention
is is definitely on Twitter but I think
I mean the point that that Viva made
about his susceptibility to government
um pressure
in a way it's actually ideal because
everyone in in certainly in in this High
state power regime that we're in right
now everyone is susceptible to
government power so the more powerful
and influential and popular person is
uh the better chance he has of resisting
that government power and and plus what
are we what what alternatives are we
positing it's the government power
versus what there is right now which he
turns out was actually an entirely
Democratic party op being run under the
cover of a private company yeah
Viva are you surprised how many people
sort of openly are upset with you on
like the guys literally just come in and
say hey I'm going to defend Free Speech
as much as possible I'm not going to put
my hand on the scale you would think
that most people would be for that yet
he's got aocs panties and a tizzy and
and everything else I am not not I'm not
surprised it is the people who have the
worst ideas that are the most fearful of
open discussion and also it's the people
who've been out there uh you know
promoting the the biggest conspiracy
theories that don't want other people
having the right to either promote their
own theories or to rebut their theories
you got uh Hillary Rodham Clinton right
after the attack on Pelosi's husband
coming out and saying this is right-wing
extremism and Elon comes out in a needle
says oh you know there are other
theories that people can pause it based
on incomplete information
the people complaining about conspiracy
theories are the ones who have
historically been promoting them the
most and then you get AOC thinking she
got under the Billionaire's skin and
someone went in to the algorithm to go
after her personal DMS it's about time
bad ideas see the light of day and
obviously none of them want that to
happen and they're threatening to leave
some of them are actually leaving it
couldn't have happened sooner and my
goodness it's fun to watch malice I'll
do a little devil's advocate here what
happens if because of Elon Musk the
trolls take over you know the trolls you
work with the trolls you're in the
underbelly of the internet what happens
if they get too much power I'm gonna
take your house Reuben and your little
dog too
um no uh the term troll has a couple of
meanings I can say this as a
professional troll it's used to describe
people who are genuinely malevolent who
go on Twitter or any other social media
site and their entire output is just to
be derisive and derogatory and
disrespectful and things like that and
that does dampen conversation if you go
to a restaurant and everyone starts
berating you and screaming at you you're
probably not going to go to the
restaurant again so something runs
anyone who runs the social media site is
going to be concerned about but what
they're defining is trolling is when
someone who's some kind of corporate
journalist or some you know demonic
academic is spewing their nonsense and
they're just responded to yes but a
multitude of people saying you're wrong
you're full of crap you know you're
being dishonest and now because in their
offices no one talks to them like this
in their daily lives no one talks to
them like this it's you know yes Mr
Jones or yes Ms Smith now they're being
called out as you know uh you know
agents of the regime now they're
regarding it as undeserved and trolling
and this has caused them a problem but I
disagree a little bit with Viva no one's
going anywhere remember when when Neil
Young said he was leaving Spotify and
then who was it some Joni Mitchell
joined on and they were trying to make
it like oh because of Rogan everyone's
leaving Spotify nothing no one happened
nothing happened no one cared uh the
best example of this is Jamila Jamil who
in April was like oh my God I am I can't
handle it here anymore oh I'm leaving
Twitter and if you look at her twit
right now she's right back she's up for
some People's Choice Award for She-Hulk
so these people don't know what borough
to Scurry to so they're gonna go where
the conversation is and and uh better
for worse right now that's Twitter I've
been following a few of them who have
been saying they're going to leave at
least one of them has in fact seemingly
left the account was no longer active I
don't know who the people are who left
I'll I'll send it afterwards no longer
active and left our two I'm not I'm I'm
no longer active every Friday night to
Saturday night okay no no but this was
like you couldn't find the account I'll
I'll tweet it out it was one person who
seemed to have made good on her promise
I had no idea you don't know that name
of it's not like it's a big name right
true I heard a rumor everyone Leone was
gonna leave it's like how can we all be
on Twitter without Tia Leone I like Deep
Impact come on you don't even know
that's the thing her name's Taya oh
great actress Love Her Lover absolutely
absolutely Ron go ahead no just do we
want to make sure we have all the names
pronounced right okay now even if even
if if 200 of them even if every attendee
of the Oscars left would that in any way
degrade the experience of of of the vast
majority of Americans
I don't think what's also interesting
about this is you know these are the
same people that for years were telling
us to build you know build our own
internet build our own social media
companies while some people did right I
built locals uh Rumble was built parlor
although it was taken out now it now
Kanye's got it I mean conservatives or
whatever did build a couple things I
suspect that the people who are all
about Equity uh really won't have the
wherewithal to to build much of anything
they don't want to go for it my concern
isn't that these people leave Twitter my
hope is that they leave the Earth and
with Elon in charge and his Rockets we
can get that achieved in our lifetime if
that would have been the move that would
have been the move that he gets them off
Twitter and then just offers them a
rocket ship into into Oblivion even King
if Stephen King Rob Reich Rob Reiner if
a bunch of these people left Twitter
yeah I would be missing people to to
criticize and show how absurdly idiotic
they are
um so true the the biggest Thorns or the
loudest smells are still going to stay
there because they need the engagement
they need the affirmation and they need
the conflict uh and that me too as well
I'm only I'm on Twitter to know what the
opposing ideas are saying because it's
no good being in an echo chamber so
let's just hope that Twitter doesn't
turn into a conservative Echo chamber
but I doubt that will ever happen no
chance I'm basically only on Twitter to
see who you're fighting with Viva that's
pretty much what that's pretty much the
only reason I'm there at this point uh
but let's let's move to the serious part
of this because it basically was exposed
this week that the government has been
working with big Tech to censor us we
all kind of knew it they had been
hinting it for quite some time uh but
now it's it's basically out in the open
we'll get to that in one second I want
to talk to you about kamikodo knives uh
you know it's time to up your kitchen
knife game people uh using traditional
techniques you know it Ron uh kamikoto
crafts beautiful knives using steel
sourced from Japan each blade is made
with techniques that have been honed and
perfected by generations of knife Smiths
they come in a beautiful heavy duty Ash
wood box and every blade is individually
inspected it and comes with a lifetime
guarantee because of their single bevel
Edge kamikoto knives can achieve a
wickedly sharp edge the kind you just
can't get with other knives these are
cut through your rib eye like butter
sharp kamikoto knives are used by
several chefs working with Michelin star
restaurants around the world they make
amazing gifts gifts that come in
beautiful boxes you can maintain each
knives edge with one of kamikoto's
sharpening wet stones and like I said
they're so confident in their product
that each and every knife comes with a
lifetime guarantee if you go ahead and
buy now kamikota is often offering you
an extra fifty dollars off site wide go
to commiecoto.com Reuben and use the
offer code Reuben for an extra fifty
dollars off
k-a-m-i-k-o-t-o.com rumen kamikodo.com
Reuben and now back to me okay so the
big story really was that the government
has been infringing on our Free Speech
surprise surprise we've got some info
from the daily wire
hundreds of internal documents exposed
top U.S government agencies working
closely with social media companies like
Facebook and Twitter to censor American
freedom of speech under the guise of
fighting disinformation over over
several years as obtained and reported
by The Intercept one of the Cozy
relationships highlighted in the report
shows a text from earlier this year
between former DHS official and current
Microsoft executive Matt Masterson and
Jen easterly a DHS director saying quote
the government needs to get the private
sector needs to get more comfortable
with government according to Fang this
is Lee fangley's a journalist at The
Intercept according to the report Fang
emphasizes key takeaways showing that
DHS plans to Target inaccurate
information on topics such as the
origins of the covid-19 pandemic and the
efficacy of covid-19 vaccines racial
Justice U.S withdrawal from Afghanistan
and the nature of U.S support to Ukraine
so let me start with you Ron here
because when I saw this whole thing a
couple days ago well first off it did
not surprise me as everyone watching
this knows back in July of 2021 I
tweeted out that vaccines weren't
working that they were prepping us for
booster shots that mandates were coming
I was banned from Twitter so I am not
surprised that it had something to do
with perhaps the government what I
called you about was well what is the
recourse if if this all bears out to be
true which it seems like it is and the
media is ignoring it so you know it's
kind of true what is your recourse any
of us talking right now or anyone
watching this that puts information out
there publicly and then the government
comes and forces a private company to
censor that information
you know Dave the last time you and I
spoke on the air
was when we were in the company of Rogan
oh Handley DC draino who called out this
precise
precise thing with receipts at the state
level
at the state level and next month in
December we have our ninth circuit
argument uh in an attempt to
reverse the District Court ruling that
threw the case out on the basis of
something happened to do with the
alignment of the planets and I mean just
it makes no sense but
what what people are going to be doing
and what is going to be a lot like what
we did so I mean on the private level
they're going let's take a step back
this is government action on that is
being outsourced to private
to private companies when a private
company does the Dirty Work that the
government itself
cannot do Under the Constitution that
private entity becomes the government
under the law that's called State action
what has been described by that
intercept article is State action that
means
not only can you sue the government
which who cares the government couldn't
care less there's no accountability the
money's not theirs they keep they do
whatever they want but if suing suing
the
State Arms that we know as Twitter and
Facebook that's going to make a big
difference that is an absolute Game
Changer and Bravo to The Intercept which
remember is the outlet that kicked out
Glenn Greenwald for being too
much of a journalist right going too far
against the left-wing narrative they
nonetheless went ahead and published
this article that's amazing to me right
so it's fascinating to me because it's
like okay can we sue the government what
are we suing the government for it's our
own money but they've they've outsourced
the tyranny in essence Viva you're also
a lawyer you come from Canada where you
guys do not have First Amendment
protections but uh this has got to be
pretty annoying for uh Canadian as well
I look I'm a Canadian lawyer a Quebec
attorney more specifically so I'm not a
lawyer in the States but I've learned a
little bit in the last few years
especially with my you know with Robert
Barnes as a mentor and the argument is
going to be are they acting as state
actors you know every the defense has
always been private companies section
two theater Community if you don't like
it it's a private company uh the
argument the flip side to that was well
if they're doing what the government is
telling them to do they become State
actors the flip side argument to that is
and it's going to be the government's
position we didn't coerce them we didn't
tell them what to do this was just
recommendations they did it on their own
so it's still private actors still
section 230 immunity it's all a load of
garbage I mean we've known it for a
while now we've known about the back
channels since saki accidentally you
know mentioned it um it's it's egregious
it takes a judge with a little bit of uh
judicial honesty judicial Integrity to
say when the government nudges you
that's effectively a a proverbial gun to
your head I mean they know damn well
when you get a visit from the FBI to
Zuckerberg saying oh mate watch out for
disinformation we know that that's the
mobster coming saying you have a nice
business here it would be a shame if
something happens to it it's about time
it's going to take many many lawsuits
because one has to pierce the the
reluctance of the courts this is one big
step closer assuming all of the details
are true yeah that's a great point and
what's interesting about this malice I
think is that it's not first off we kind
of knew it right saki admitted it as as
Viva just said over a year ago she said
that the administration Flags posts for
Facebook so it's not forcing them
necessarily but yes it is that Mafia
tactic maybe we'll break you up maybe
we'll show up at the offices Etc but
what I thought was interesting about
what they uncovered is that it wasn't
just covid related the Afghanistan
withdrawal racial Justice I mean we have
been manipulated in ways that we truly
can't fathom that that's what I think
you know well here's one way that we're
manipulated that I think uh you some
people on this show might be
um not comfortable acknowledging which
is that the idea of the Republican party
is going to do anything about this uh
there these the DHS and Facebook and
Twitter are absolutely right in pursuing
this course of action and maintaining
their own power because there's no
consequences whatsoever for them as
entities or as individuals for putting
forth this charade on the American
people we saw what had started during
the Trump Administration
it has to have started during the Trump
admission no my point my point is if you
look at what happened with Kavanaugh
none of the Democratic senators none of
the staffers uh Julia Julie swetnik
Michael avenatti had consequences and as
a result of this
um Chuck Grassley who was a major uh
Senator he's I think 89 he's up for
reelection he sent off a sternly Written
Letter to the Department of Justice you
know asking oh my goodness how could
this have happened and nothing came up
if they completely ignored it he sent a
letter A year later so I think that
people who think this red wave that
might happen on Tuesday is going to
result in some kind of pushback even
though it would be to the Republican
party's advantage to make sure that the
fingers not put on the scale against
them are uh if not delusional at least
strongly mistaken in their thinking it's
just really kind of disturbing
I think we should all jump in on that
one but well because malice might be a
little too black pilled I I think this
my book's called the white pillow I'm
not black hills at all well no no no no
no no no no cynical cynical uh if you if
you are thinking that salvation is Gonna
Come Through the Republican party that's
blue pill that's it perspective so this
is my point it's not a red wave that I
anticipate witnessing it's a populist
wave and I I agree with you you know
it's a big club and we ain't in it and
the Republicans had full control a few
years ago did nothing Trump had full did
nothing on certain issues this I think
is more of a populist wave that we're
seeing right now because people the
people are fed up with everything left
and right they're fed up with seeing the
crenshaws support billions and billions
of dollars to the Ukraine while people
can't afford gas here so I I'm hoping
and maybe I'm a little white pilled I'm
hoping it's a populist wave and not a
red wave because I don't trust one arm
of the government more than another wait
I gotta ask a question you are you
telling me with a straight face that
Mitch McConnell and Kevin McCarthy are
interested in populism
I don't think so but I think if they're
interested in power we agree right
Michael uh no because I think populism
is a threat to their power so they're
interested in squashing it as much as
possible no I think they're interested
in writing it and and and giving it as
much tribute as they need to to maintain
power and I think there's a number of
candidates who are younger candidates
Joe Kent I'm going to forget a bunch of
others
um oh come on a JD Vance I think there's
a number of candidates who are populists
younger that will be the next Generation
these these people are you know they're
on their last political legs uh so
whether or not they are power hungry
everybody in politics is I think what
we're seeing is a younger generation of
populist Representatives coming up
because the people are fed up with
everything by the way malice I have no
Illusions about what the Republicans
actually are I just think that they're a
little bit better than the Democrats and
certainly at a state level they can do a
lot more to maintain people being free
but I agree we do all these sham uh
they're not trials we do these sham
ridiculous things where Ted Cruz gets up
there and I like Ted Cruz but then asks
Zuckerberg all these questions they
catch them all red-handed they get them
in all the lies and you're right nothing
nothing ever changes so I don't expect
anything truly magical to happen
um but I think it might be a little bit
better and I I also agree with Ron that
it would be more about riding the wave
rather than than doing anything sort of
proactively
arguably there's also there's a supply
and a demand issue so on the terms of
will there be retribution will there
will there be consequences presidents
pretty much still run the country so
even if you the Republicans have both
houses of Congress they don't have a
veto proof majority besides federal
judges are the last
they decide what the law is in this
country so you could pass all the
legislation you want it's going to be up
to the Judiciary what the actual law is
in this country but on the other hand
there's the push phenomenon which is
when the Democrats control all of both
houses of Congress
that results in things happening that
won't happen if the if the Republicans
control Congress so these are subtle
distinctions but I think Michael and I'm
going to call you Michael I know that
the the custom has become to call you
malice for some reason on this podcast
but but I think you're a good boy
and I'm going to give you I'm going to
call you by your first name
okay cool story I think it's I think
it's not as big
this is a Grandpa Simpson moment what is
happening you don't realize that they've
called you malice several times I call
him malice I call him Mouse wait all
right hang on here because that's my
name but but Ron let me just ask you a
question
if you if you have these Congressional
hearings and you have people like
Zuckerberg or agents of Twitter lying to
Congress under oath is it your belief
that when there is a Republican
president a republican Department of
Justice they're going to have the
slightest bit of consequence of what
they did meanwhile Steve bannon's going
to jail what is your honest opinion well
if the Department of Justice is still
under the executive so like right that's
not the Republican Department of Justice
if we if we're four years from now we
have a Republican president two
I mean we're two years after that so
we've changed everything over okay yeah
no I don't think so I I don't I don't
but I don't think that's necessary
I don't think that's necessary to result
in a very meaningful Improvement
because I'm not I'm actually not an
advocate and I got killed on this all
the time on Twitter
um I'm not an advocate of being as
abusive of power and as cynical and
wicked as the Democrats are because now
it's our turn I know many people think
well that makes me a wimp and maybe even
a rhino uh well I've got lunatic calling
me a mega lawyer on Twitter for the last
two months two weeks but
I don't think that's the way to go I
think the way to go is to actually seek
to have good government but at least
let's first get out of get the bad
government out
so the so your plan for the future is
when the Democrats are in power they're
they're vindictive and blocking people
away and the Republicans in power they
sit in their hands they have good
government can you see how that needle
is going to turn over the next coming
years in what direction
well the trend listen the oh you're
asking me these questions in order to
demonstrate the fact that more
aggressive
more aggressive action on behalf of
Republicans in power has to happen I'm
not going to disagree with you what
we've seen so far has been manifestly
insufficient and that includes during
the Trump Administration and it includes
you know you know something has to be
done differently do Republicans realize
not going back to viva's point
do Republicans realize what side of the
bread is buttered
this you know this time around maybe
maybe not I don't know but again Michael
all we can do it's a two-party system so
this is what we got and I'll say to
malice and you don't become I mean you
don't defeat the enemy by becoming the
enemy and you don't defeat the monster
by becoming the monster so I would not
like to see the same type of actual
judicial abuse but I would not mind
seeing open hearings you know with fauci
with a number of others who were in
charge of the coveted response I
wouldn't mind seeing open hearings on a
number of issues where at the very least
sunlight itself would reveal something
and then it would be up to the people to
decide well how much of this ship do we
need to write in the direction it's a
big ship it turns slowly and it has to
be righted slowly but malice I'm curious
do you think that let's say there is
this red wave and I get all of your
reservations of why these people won't
change anything and as I said they might
just be marginally better in that or at
least stop a little bit of the
bloodletting or something like that but
do you not think there's any chance that
if there really was this massive Red
Wave and that we hauled out let's say a
fauci or some somebody in front of real
Congressional hearings you think there's
literally zero chance that anyone would
pay any price well there's not literally
zero chance but I mean you just heard
Ron and Viva say that you know on the
one hand you're going to have vindictive
people putting being put in jail you can
have people lives ruins and the response
should be hearings where nothing happens
as a consequence this is just on paper
which which of those two teams would you
rather be the one who's imprisoning
their political opponents or the one
who's having hearings and everyone the
thing what you I think you guys are
missing or you disagree with is you
think people like Vijaya or the former
CEO of Twitter or will exp or or Lois
Lerner would experience anything
remotely close to shame so if they're on
on TV and Ted Cruz and Rand Paul are
wagging their finger at them and telling
them terrible this is a point of Pride
for them to take back to their team and
they know nothing's going to happen
result of them so of course they would
do it again there were no if you have no
concept if I'm a shoplifter right and
I'm stealing from this store and once in
a while this is how it's happening with
crime in different cities and I get
caught once in a while at while after
return turn the whatever I stole the
stereo but I left out on the street I'm
going to keep trying to steal the stereo
because sometimes I'm going to get away
with it so yeah I think the one the one
difference let me finish my point as
long as Republicans are sitting here on
this panel publicly saying well we don't
want to be mean we don't want to be the
monster the monster is going to beat the
villagers
yeah I think in a bizarre sense we're
actually agreeing because I I think that
there is a chance that they will have
enough juice there will be a cultural
shift after this election that there
will have to be somebody that will will
kind of pay for some of this stuff and
it won't be fully fully shared all right
last thought on this one do you know why
that's wrong because you if you don't do
it by putting people like Dr Oz in the
Senate who's campaigning on working with
the Democrats you do it by punishing the
Republican party when they nominate
people like that and making sure you put
the crazies in I I have my theories on
Dr Oz but all right wait I wanna I wanna
do one thing Viva related to you because
with all everything we're talking about
here uh you actually got suspended on
Twitter this week post Elon taking over
you were suspended because you were
talking about this this crazy Paul
Pelosi attack in San Francisco that the
police weren't watching the the cameras
there's no video footage of the whole
thing is so freaking bizarre but Hillary
and Ilan Omar know that it was a a crazy
maggot right-wing Maniac what happened
here well uh what happened can you
believe that the media has just stopped
talking about it two days yeah it's over
it's it's nuts and oh yeah no no right
we we got it all under wraps except now
the guy's pleading not guilty they don't
have the body cam footage apparently
there was a live feed of of a video
either outside Pelosi's house or ant or
inside they weren't surveilling it at
the time okay good income but that
doesn't mean that they don't have the
video footage still and I'm sure they do
because everybody has security that
keeps the video for at least 30 days no
I got locked out for an innocuous tweet
talking to Matt Gertz from Media Matters
saying dude you had a 16 thread tweet
with yourself talking about how this was
clearly right wing now everyone's going
to be duped by Elon Musk misinformation
and you've come to some pretty radical
conclusions in the absence of even
having seen the video footage which
nobody's seen yet at the time we didn't
know where the clothes were because we
were still under the impression he was
in his underwear that's been pulled back
and you call other people conspiracy
theorists and then within 30 seconds of
that tweet I was locked out for 26 hours
back in tweet still up never deleted the
Tweet uh no explanation from Twitter as
of yet Elon I expect an explanation
well I assume I assume you're watching
this and we all want to push Elon to
make it a better product
right what did you say about Media
Matters I'm positive Media Matters at
that time still had somebody literally
working for in other words someone on
the payroll of Media Matters or as good
as on the payroll for Media Matters
was at the switch
in Twitter headquarters I mean
they work hand in glove together that
was a direct response to your hitting
upgurch can I ask can I make a point
Kevin McCarthy if should he become
speaker of the house this is widely
expected after Tuesday's election is in
a position to have hearings and say look
we're going to take the Democrats
concerns of threats on politicians lives
seriously this is no joke this affects
all of us look at Steve scalise look at
Paul Pelosi we're going to have a full
investigation into the circumstances
that led to the Speaker of the House
Paul Pelosi's speaker House's husband
Paul Pelosi being attacked we're going
to look at all the footage we're going
to look at the circumstances he can blow
up this story and make it a public
spectacle and make it really twist the
knife on the Democrats and there's in my
view almost no possibility that he's
going to do this this is a great example
of the asymmetry of how the Democrats
work and how the Republicans work malice
I love that you're laying down the
gauntlet with him and I'm fairly certain
I'm interviewing him a day or two after
the election in DC so I will ask him
that myself how about that and then I
will and watch him tap dance all right
let's see that that is the great
challenge right if they get the win what
are you going to do with it that's what
we're all wondering basically I want to
throw to one more thing on this before
we move on which is that uh are
incredible press secretary this White
House Press Secretary my God is this
amazing does she has anyone been more
qualified or better at their job in the
history of the world than Corinne
Jean-Pierre female lesbian women women
of color
secretaries unprecedented
here she is talking about this whole
Tech censorship collusion thing yeah so
um
look
we'll say this
um the the administration
um the bite Administration remains fully
uh committed to our mission to protect
the security and resilience of our um of
of our you know elections at Safeguard
election infrastructure that includes
combat combating disinformation that is
something that we are committed to
malice I feel like she's like a sort of
living walking breathing version of why
you're an anarchist that it's like
anyone that gets in any of these
positions of power they just become
useless parts of the machine I I don't
want to say I feel bad for her but it's
hard for me to think what I would do
differently if I was her if the if
there's the receipts right if that's
your gift yes and you know that you have
to get up there and spew lies the
Washington press Court they're not all
dumb I mean these people are smart they
sometimes ask for tough questions I
sometimes ask myself okay if I was in
her position uh what would I do
differently and if she's really up
against it because thanks to social
media as opposed to you know before
social media you you could be whatever
lie you want you you got to just
convince that one or two journalists
that what you're saying will have to
repeat your lie and it's fine but now
thanks to social media you there's
receipts 24 7. if I spew one lie today
in five minutes it's gonna someone's
gonna have the counter or the the tweet
of mine from 10 years ago where I said
the contrary I don't know what I would
do differently in her position she's
really uh maybe I would have resigned
you know and like saki had the sense to
do
yeah viva do you feel any sympathy for
her I mean we everyone knows she's going
up there and lying about everything
that's sort of what the gig is in the
first place as a White House Press
Secretary but she has like an
extraordinary level of it because of the
Endless amount of lies and the fact that
some of this stuff's getting exposed in
real time now which as malice points out
that wouldn't have happened say 15 years
ago do I feel bad for her I feel bad for
everybody even people who don't know
that they should feel bad for themselves
what what really nauseates me about
jean-pierre's particular situation is
she is being exploited racially
genderized sexual or she's being
exploited it's the ultimate Act of
racism actually to take someone and use
them as a political tool so that any
critique of them on the substance can be
spun off as being racist uh homophobic
uh you know gender whatever she is being
abused through her race gender identity
uh sexual orientation she's being used
as a political Pawn by Joe Biden a man
with the history of this that's what
pisses me off about this entire story
she's a liar yeah I mean she's a liar
she's reading talking points on pages
she's flipping through to see what are
my talking points when asked on this so
I can avoid the question and just do my
bidding uh Joe Biden's bidding but that
she gets up there and on day one I'm the
first black openly lesbian person to
take this position uh call me whatever
that's irrelevant to me do your job
properly which I guess she is for Biden
but she was appointed on that its
exploitation of the highest order and it
should offend it should offend Democrats
there I said it
Ron I think you're the Elder Statesman
in This Crew here uh by by uh you want
me to talk about Nixon's press secretary
yeah well just has there ever been an
Administration that you can think of and
we can even go back to before any of us
were born that just the entire thing was
a series of lies that I I'm truly at the
point with these people and we're going
to get to some Biden Clips in a moment
nobody related to this Administration
can say anything honest at any level at
any time you're right Dave and and
it's an amazing thing to watch and and
you know the Press secretaries are
perfect because she's supposed to be the
one who's the best the most convincing
who's the professional spin doctor so
that everyone else might sound a little
awkward but then she can come out with
the master massage and make it all
better she can't because it's that bad
and what we've seen happen in this in
this two-year period is that the
Democrats have said we're gonna be that
bad
and you're and we're gonna and we're not
even gonna really pretend otherwise and
you're not gonna be able to do a damn
thing about it so we're going to put a
zombie in the white house we're going to
run for the Pennsylvania Senate a stroke
victim who doesn't even put on a suit
and tie once or maybe once he did for
the entire I mean people who are mad you
see what the trend had been was to not
eat was to give up and have any
Statesmen whatsoever so you have these
incredible mediocrities in the Senate
you know what you used to be considered
to be you know the upper the upper
chamber the you know the most exclusive
club in the world and now it's just it's
essentially a bunch of non-entities but
now we're going to go beyond
non-entities to top to bottom absolute
ABS people who are not you would not
hire to work in your in your in your in
your office or your ice cream store
well speaking of non-entities let's move
to the final segment because Joe Biden
knowing that things are not looking good
he gave a speech a couple days ago to
just try to scare the high hell out of
everybody who should we fear most well
of course it's those extremist Maga
Republicans yet now extreme maggot
Republicans aim to question not only the
legitimacy of past elections
but elections being held now
and into the future
the extreme Maga element of the
Republican party which is a minority
that party as I said earlier
but is this driving force
is trying to succeed where they failed
in 2020.
to suppress the right of Voters
and subvert the electoral system itself
malice you know we've got early voting
all over the country I haven't seen any
video of anyone being suppressed black
people not having IDs and being turned
around I did see a couple videos this
week of Hillary once again uh claiming
that Republicans were going to steal the
election although she called Trump an
illegitimate president and Stacy Abrams
uh while they're having record early
voting turnout in Georgia claiming that
voters are being suppressed there I'm
starting to think these people are
disingenuous but it's it's kind of funny
because in terms of campaign issues vote
for democracy seems to be a slogan that
is not really going to Rally turn out
and turnout is of course as everyone
knows what drives elections it's not
really the will of the voters but
frankly if if the argument is as Biden
said earlier that voting for Republican
is voting against democracy that's the
best argument for republicans in my
third democracy is in obscenity and the
idea that my neighbor should have a say
over my life is just absolutely insane
and I think we're going to be seeing
that I don't think they're they're
crying wolf I think think we're going to
be seeing in the next 10 15 years
republican-led states that are going to
be tightening restrictions on ballot
access and I think that's a good thing
because there's far too many people who
have a say about things that they have
no idea about and shouldn't be running
their mouths about and I say this
ironically and not ironically
well okay so here's another clip from
that very same thing it's a perfect
segue thank you uh malice Biden's
already warning us that there might be
election Shenanigans just in two days
from now we know that more and more
ballots are cast in early voting or by
mail in America
we know
that many states don't start counting
those ballots so after the polls close
on November 8th
that means in some cases we won't know
the winner of the election
for a few days until after a few days
after the election
it takes time to count all legitimate
ballots
an illegal and orderly manner
Ron it seems pretty freaking obvious am
I am I cynical or what I mean is he
basically just saying hey you know a
pipe is going to burst somewhere in
Philadelphia on Election night and uh
you know what can we do about it okay so
let me tell you one thing about
Philadelphia you don't need a pipe to
burst to cheating Philadelphia
cheating in Philadelphia is open and
notorious it's been going on for decades
Republicans have done nothing about it
whatsoever
pipe bursts are in other places but uh
you know my understanding is that um you
know I can't reveal too much but I can
tell you the GOP has sent out Crack
teams of plumbers
to key precincts where there will be
repairs available 24 7. so not this time
not this time Satan
I mean Viva this this concept though
that you know they're prepping people to
just not expect election results on
Election night it's gotten worse and
worse over the last couple years but now
they're just outright telling you hey we
just got to figure out enough time to
get the results we want I I I'm young
I'm only 42. when in the history of of
modern politics have we gotten used to
the idea that you do not know the
results as a rule on Election Day itself
it's occasionally happened when there
was litigation I remember back in 2000
but now it's become the rule that you
have your elections and then it takes
you a few days sometimes a week to count
the ballots this is this is a Devolution
of Technology not an evolution I don't
know if that's the right word but we're
regressing this is not progress but the
idea like I come from Canada the idea
that we have that you make it so easy
that people can vote from their living
room in their pajamas in Canada vote you
have to have a piece of ID two documents
to show that you still live at that
address the idea that they've made it so
easy that you could just take bags full
to drop off boxes and then we'll count
them later and the dates don't really
matter if they came in you know the day
after it's Preposterous it's abusive and
the only reason some people tolerate it
is because they are still running around
saying Trump is a jagoff in their in
their political ads because that's the
platform
malice do you kind of like it when you
hear Biden say something like that
because it makes the whole thing feel
less legitimate
I I like it because there's a huge wing
of conservatism whose only ideology is
just doing the opposite wherever the
Democrats want uh and since I'm someone
who is very much interested in
abolishing democracy and regarding it as
antithetical to Liberty uh if he starts
putting it out there that like if you
vote against me you're against democracy
that's going to make a lot of people
like well wait a minute let me take a
look at this against democracy thing um
and I think what the the other fellows
mentioned are two great mechanisms that
uh Governors can do to tighten up the
election meaning eliminating early
voting eliminating mail-in ballots
except perhaps maybe for veterans or
excuse me people who are serving uh and
can't be resident to their state but
these are actionable things that would
Advantage the Republicans just in the
same way Democrats are interested in
furthering immigration because they know
that those immigrants would tend to vote
Democrats but there's very little
appetite on the Republican side to
change the rules that would end up
benefiting them because their only role
effectively is to just serve as
mouthpieces to some big opposition but
to do absolutely nothing once they're in
power
well with just three days before this
big election uh MSNBC which as I always
tell people if you watch it knowing that
it's a televised mental institution it's
much more entertaining uh they're trying
to freak people out to the highest level
I mean this one was truly this is truly
truly bananas here's a presidential
historian on uh what's about to happen
this speech seemed in some sense is more
specific about the developments that
we're seeing everywhere from the Arizona
poll stalkers to the Secretary of State
who who refuse to uh say that they'll
accept the elections what do you view as
the key takeaway of the speech tonight
we could be six days away from losing
our rule of law and losing a situation
where we have elections that we all can
rely on a historian will say what was at
stake tonight and this week was the fact
whether we will be a democracy in the
future whether our children will be
arrested and conceivably killed we're on
the edge of a brutal authoritarian
system and it could be a week away
Viva we're not only losing democracy but
they're also going to kill the children
I mean what is going on here I should
have been wearing the shirt that says
confession through projection because
the only P the only party that's been
jailing people I'll save I'll save the
I'll I'll not get into the killing of
people but jailing people
bastardizing democracy has been the the
party in power for the last two years
jailing Bannon jailing all of their
political adversaries acquitting all of
their you know political allies this man
is describing what the party that is
trying to preserve its control is and
has been doing it's confession through
projection through and through but my
goodness that's hyperbolic even for that
individual who I've never heard of
before
malice I take it that you'd be okay with
some kidnapping and killing of children
in the name of Liberty well only the fat
and ugly ones but I I do want to point
out that some of us do grow up
and have normal happy lives please
but Viva I just want to make your point
you just made my argument for me the
Democrats are imprisoning their
political opponents and and you get to
sit here and kind of roll your eyes and
laugh about it which of those two sides
is winning the people laughing or the
people doing the imprisoning which side
would you want to be on I I I'll if
malice you might call me the person who
would rather die than kill but I would
rather not be the people doing the evil
so in as much as I I think repercussions
for those who do I would not want to be
that monster I wouldn't I wouldn't feel
better living with myself like that than
living as a victim of of that type of
violence okay and that is exactly why
America is in the state it's in today
because of people like you on the right
I'm Canadian dude
well he also wisely moved to Florida
where we have some defenses against
against some of this stuff and by the
way Florida malice is doing some of the
things that you were asking some of the
states to do related to voting we are
encouraging uh in-person voting you have
to have an ID they're discouraging
mail-in ballots although they're doing a
little bit because of the hurricane so
there are it's a little easier I think
maybe for Viva to say it here in the
safety of Florida because it's true
rather than in Canada but let's do one
last thing here real clear politics has
put out I think what will be their last
election prediction uh we've got the the
map this is the Senate race and they're
predicting 54 Republicans 46 for the
Democrats that's pretty bullish so that
has Arizona going to Blake Masters I
think you've got Pennsylvania there
going to Oz uh what else do we have
there yeah I mean you can see Rubio
obviously will stay in Florida New
Hampshire Ron if you're feeling good
about this thing feeling pretty good I
mean it is true I'm often reminding
people who who fret about cheating that
cheating the kind of cheating that we
saw in 2020
isn't really an issue in Congressional
races but Statewide races it can be you
can you can run off as many Philadelphia
County balances necessary to overcome a
senate vote and yet what we see is that
Democrats are panicking Democrats are
throwing money in other words it's
obviously not as easy to cheat
as many people seem to think because
Democrats are
livid and terrified and and they're
doing all this advance
vetting uh I mean uh softening the
ground for disaster so is there gonna
there's gonna be cheating but yeah I'm
pretty bullish I'm you know
I like how things are going Viva bullish
uh I I think what what Ron means is
fortification not cheating but uh if if
I'm trying not to get booted off YouTube
today thank you no well because it's
it's the it's the legal it's the legal
cheating control change the rules change
the system control the flow of
information a well-funded group of cabal
you know whatever
um if if my senses are right I see a
massive bullish type run uh the cynic
and me gets worried that uh the results
don't reflect the sentiment
malice I'm gonna force you to finish up
here with the final word if you believe
that something is coming that's bullish
and red and the wave is on its way do
you see any way that it it turns into
something positive say short term into
long term yeah the the two races I'm
most concerned with and the two
candidates I've endorsed are Herschel
Walker uh who in his autobiography
talked about hearing voices telling him
to kill someone who delivered his car
six days late and he played Russian
Roulette so many times he lost track
account
and he's better than Warnock and John
fetterman in Pennsylvania who absolutely
has to be in the Senate because I'm
looking forward to the moment where like
the movie scanners his head just
explodes and covers the senate floor
with pieces of his skull and brain so
please run out and vote for John
fetterman in Pennsylvania and Herschel
Walker in Georgia
malice you know I know you often like to
dress up when you do the show I'm
demanding you come as Heath Ledger's
Joker next time I'm more of a Caesar
Romero Joker but yeah
fair enough you're definitely more Cesar
Romero uh all right guys well have a
great weekend I'm gonna finish up for a
few minutes solo uh but good seeing you
guys as always and we will we will do
this again uh all right guys a couple a
couple comments on locals and then I
want to uh discuss one other thing
before we get to this big election on
Tuesday uh Amy says I certainly hope
that there will be enough new blood in
Congress that will stand up for the
people and Against the Machine right
that's that's really the issue that
malice is talking about it's like okay
if we get these Republicans in is there
any evidence to think they will do
anything other than just protect their
their new level of power
I don't know I think that's why the
state level matters way more than the
national level it just is the case do I
expect the Senate even if it's 54
Republicans to do anything amazing and
really uh drag fauci out there and bring
out the big tech people and then do
anything about it I'm not so sure but
what we can control is our local lives
and I think Florida is the best example
of that Peter says I hope the American
experiment will continue to survive if
censorship takes hold in the U.S I see
no hope well that's why this censorship
thing has been so important that's why
it was so vital to expose what the CIA
and the FBI were doing with big Tech and
ironically I mean this was we should
have grabbed that headline I checked the
day that the story broke to see if this
this story was on CNN's front page it
was not however they did have a front
page article about how The Oath Keepers
which is I suppose some sort of Mega
linked group that on January 6 that a
whole bunch of them had lunch at Olive
Garden and racked up a 400 bill that was
on the front page of CNN and as Conor
pointed out the breadsticks are free so
a 400 Bill there I mean it's a lot of
pasta so that's the level of Disconnect
between reality and what mainstream
media has given us uh Elizabeth says the
government needs to get more comfortable
with freedom
man that's the way it was set up and uh
wouldn't that be sweet well we're doing
it right here in Florida we really are
um I'm very hopeful guys I don't think
all of our problems will be solved by
politics if we get the red wave as as
malice lays out like the machine just
kind of is the machine and and things
maybe a little bit can get marginally
better here and there
um but I think we can make a major dent
in this cultural war that we've been
losing for a long time so make sure if
you can early vote that you get out and
do it or get there on Tuesday I'm taking
my whole team out Tuesday morning we'll
try to do some videos from the polling
place uh I'm excited I think they're
they're really really is a chance oh and
speaking of a chance by the uh I just
yesterday I interviewed Tudor Dixon who
is running against Gretchen Whitmer in
Michigan nobody thought she could win
the polls are basically neck and neck
right now we're going to put that up
tomorrow we did it on the Fly she's on a
on a bus tour right now uh trying to get
those last couple rallies out so you can
catch that tomorrow like And subscribe
if you have not if you want to play
along live during the show
reubenreport.locals.com uh oh and my
interview with Tina Forte who is the
woman running against AOC yes AOC is
could be out too anything is possible
I'm telling you anything is possible uh
oddly Tina is not getting any mainstream
coverage our interview is up across
platforms right now
on that note that's it for me for today
but the DeSantis team put out this video
this morning and we thought it was a
nice way to go out for the weekend have
a good one everybody
and on the eighth day
God looked down on his planned paradise
and said I need a protector
so God made a fighter
God said I need somebody willing to get
up before Dawn kiss his family goodbye
travel thousands of miles for no other
reason than to serve the people to save
their jobs their livelihoods their
Liberty their happiness
so God made a fighter
God said I need someone to be strong
Advocate truth in the midst of Hysteria
someone who challenges conventional
wisdom and isn't afraid to defend what
he knows to be right and just
so God made a fighter
God said I need somebody who will take
the arrows stand firm in the wake of
unrelenting attacks look a mother in the
eyes and tell her that her child will be
in school
she can keep her job go to church eat
dinner with friends
and hold the hand of an aging parent
taking their breath for the last time
so God made a fighter
God said I need a family man
a man who would laugh and then sigh
and then reply with smiling eyes
when his daughter says
she wants to spend her life doing what
Dad does
so God made a fighter
foreign